the rim on Russell and that is number  three on Russell and a chance for a  three-point play for birth and that's  been a big reason the Knicks knocked  down some three-point shots early in the  game it's opened up the floor but the  ease in which they've been able to drive  and get themselves to the basket has not  been typical of what we've seen out of  this Brooklyn Nets defense as of late I  think Russell has a case to be upset  with that  yeah but beers three we talked about  Shabazz and his grittiness he he's had a  couple it's old it really low D'Angelo  Russell you see him in the corner  hopping up and down hopping up and down  now the technical was not initially  indicated it actually came a little  while later and then D'Angelo Russell  says the Kenny acted Sid my fault he's  like yeah I got three fouls and I'm  still giving up Harris quick initial  step at big city to give it